[Music]
this is star talk sports edition got
with me my co-host Gary writer Gary hey
Neil all right and I got chuck chuck
baby how you doing man hey what's up
Neil and today we're going to talk about
baseball data analytics ooh
ooh now we all think we know something
about baseball and not all not we don't
know well because there's so much time
the announcers fill between pitches the
that is the 37th pitch he's thrown in
the second inning the first time that's
how it's like where does all this data
come from and why are they talking about
it and does it have any meaning and
where's it going and does it make the
team win there are people who specialize
in that and one such person is our guest
who spent this summer of 2022 interning
with the New York Yankees data group and
his name is Ben Morrow Ben welcome to
start talk
thank you it's great to be here yeah so
the quantitative analysis associate
that's a cool title especially for the
New York Yankees which is my home team
being native of the Bronx and you're a
PhD student in a joint program in
finance and economics and University of
Chicago in their Booth School of
Business so Ben what is a quantitative
analysis associate and
uh we all want to know if you did that
for the Yankees did you have a free
parking space
exactly
uh well well thanks again again for
having me on here
um so every baseball team now uh
basically has uh an in-house analytics
Department uh in fact most of all major
league sports now have an in-house
analytics Department
um and that's because at the end of the
day what these teams are trying to do is
win and uh really that's what they try
to do surprise that was a new thing make
money for their owners but a lot of it
has to do with winning and uh you're
trying to manufacture ads wherever you
can uh for the fans that's gonna you
know from facing towards the fans most
of what you see is what the players do
on the pitch but anything that uh you
can do to sort of uh uh improve strategy
uh in informed by data um there's going
to be a team in the back office that's
trying to figure out what to do again
every team has this I think in baseball
it's a it's much more advanced than than
in other sports and I can sort of talk
more about why I think that's the case
but uh that's effectively what I would
do now uh there are parking spaces
obviously I was taking the D train but
um it's easy enough to get there
um so Ben I have to ask you we are 20
years or so on from Bill James and
Moneyball right and Billy Bean and all
the rest of it
um so he changed totally changed the
game in terms of analytics where are we
now as opposed to where he was then yeah
so I think I mean obviously what Bill
James did for the game um was incredible
um and I think he really got the whole
statistics Revolution going uh Chevrolet
would you say he's the father of
sabermetrics
for sure he's the father of saber
veterans doesn't mean that there wasn't
anything going on before that
um uh and you know even the the
statistics he was calling from sort of
box scores and games we had much more
data available uh for that than for
other sports but he certainly
revolutionized the game
um and and sort of brought forth uh uh a
whole new set of statistics and it's you
know historical abstract which is Big
magnum opus about this uh uh certainly
set the stage um now since then there's
been a lot of changes so which is what
historical abstracts is the his public a
book that he published yeah a book that
he published um dozens of books didn't
he he published dozens of books but that
sort of is big one that sort of goes
through everything
um it's it's a long read I'm not sure I
would recommend it unless you're really
into it but um it is sort of like the
most famous One
um I'm sure he appreciates your
endorsement there Ben
uh whatever you do people don't read
this so Ben what was being overvalued
previous to the sort of psychometrics
and what was being undervalued that's a
good question because obviously people
want to that shifted everything shifted
so that's fascinating
sure so um certainly what was being
undervalued was sort of how people get
on base right basically on base it gets
on base if you think back to the movie
um so you know things like uh getting
walked which is sort of one of those
that don't know it's when the picture
throws four you know pitches outside the
zone until you automatically take first
base that's sort of you know a somewhat
unsexy event that happens as you sort of
you know walk to first base that's why
it's called a walk and you know you're
not hitting it it's not clear the extent
to which the demonstration of skill but
that's basically as as valuable you know
at the end of the day as getting a hit
right in Little League they told us walk
is as good as is as good as a hit so
okay why is that really a revelation I
mean
um it was somewhat of a revelation in
the sense that I think people didn't
recognize it as much as a skill
um beforehand so some people are better
at getting them on base also too little
Leaguers aren't getting paid
how do you know that Chuck how do you
know that when I paid when I'm paying
you millions of dollars I am not paying
you to walk the first place you know but
but you're right it's on base it doesn't
make a difference how you get there
right so it is the skill so the shift
would have been that some people walk
more than others and so it's not just a
failure of the picture to get you out
it's a skill of the better
and collect the balls so that they okay
so maybe that's the skill set that was
unappreciated oh absolutely not just
simply that a walk is the same as a hit
right battling the pitcher battling the
pitcher so you you see guys that do this
where
um you know they might have a two and
two count right and they're just they're
just forcing the picture to keep
throwing because they're getting a just
a little bit of that ball you know
they're falling off falling off falling
off falling off and now it's a full
count you know what I'm doing my good
pit those are my best pitches exactly
right yeah yeah you're raising the pitch
count and and listen you're increasing
your chances of getting a hit or getting
walked yeah yeah it's also not not an
invarian skill but you can also
manufacture it I think what's another
thing you figure so you know just tell
people don't swing at the first pitch
walks are going to go up
um so it's not just something that
you're born with or yeah right so that's
that's that's an acquired knowledge
through experience and then whether you
get it through your own personal
experience or someone Whispers that in
your ear but baseball as everybody knows
apart from you Ben isn't really my sport
British accent no baseball
um but I did come across something
called Pythagorean winning percentage
and power speed number which kind of
left me scratching my head to a certain
extent but I guess you could explain it
if you could yeah uh now Pythagoras was
the first person to actually give us uh
baseball data yes he was Pythagoras was
a little known he batted cleanup
laughs
he knew the angles on the game yeah you
see him on that vase don't you yeah
the Grecian urn has a baseball player
well what is that Ben what is that yeah
so uh the Pythagorean winds percentage
um is basically the idea that sort of
wind can be you know somewhat somewhat
random in the sense that you can you
know just win by one Runner just lose by
one run and that's going to show up just
as much in your winning record as you
know winning by 10 runs or winning by 20
runs right but obviously we'd like to
sort of say the team that wins by you
know 10 runs is you know a better team
than the team that just scrapes by with
one run so basically uh uh because of
that you know your winning percentage
might be a little a little random right
uh and so the the Pythagorean sort of
win formula was what one thing that Bill
James developed where he said rather
than sort of look at wins directly let's
see how well we can predict wins just
based on the runs you've scored and the
runs that have been scored against you
right and obviously your your winning
percentage should be increasing in the
runs youth sport and decreasing in the
Run scored against you and you came up
with this very nice little formula
um that's sort of the the Run score the
runs you scored squared uh over the runs
in squared squared plus the runs you've
allowed squared and that tends to
predict wins uh to a much better degree
than just sort of your winning
percentage overall so it's a way to say
if we can just use run scored and runs
aloud how well can we predict your
winning percentage based on that and
tends to be much less random as opposed
to just I we won as opposed to we won a
game this is you know taking how many
runs scored to predict you win a game
exactly yeah yeah so the point is uh
just so if I understand correctly if you
just barely win a game by run or just
barely lose a game by a run that has
enough statistical fluctuation that it's
not really measuring anything as much as
other games where you're more dominant
that's exactly right and I think the
other reason why it's valuable is a lot
of times when we're thinking about other
things in baseball like uh uh hits or
assigning sort of values we're not
assigning values in terms of probability
of a win right someone you know bats you
know 100 points higher we're not saying
this guy raised the probability of wins
by X percent we're saying this person's
four is X more runs right and so if we
want to translate that into actual
metrics like wins we need something like
this theorem that sort of has higher
predictability interesting so Ben we
started out by you saying that walks
were undervalued uh what about home runs
over the over the decades oh we all love
home runs oh oh and by the way the
walk-off home run we win by one run is
all exciting but it's interesting
because that gets the blood pumping but
had they won by five runs and they're
already ahead going into the ninth
inning that's less exciting but more
valuable to you as a predictor of wins
so but just let me ask what role do or
should home runs play in any of this
yeah so uh home runs are are sort of
very valuable
um I think that they're sort of one of
the easiest ones to quantify because
um you just you know you immediately
have the Run value you're not trying to
predict that of sample anything right
you immediately get the runs plus
whoever's on base
um so uh I think uh and obviously um we
now have sort of more home run hitters
right so I think the game's moving to a
spot where we have people who sort of
hit home runs and don't hit home runs or
we don't have as many sort of itch roads
anymore or more more consistent hitters
um so uh yeah I think I'm not sure those
uh I'm not sure how the sort of the
imputed run value of those have changed
over time I think they're the easiest to
get right probably
um because they're right there because
we all we all know remember that when
Babe Ruth first hit 50 home runs that
was more than any other entire team hit
so
clearly home runs was was not a thing at
some time early in the history of the
game and now everyone's waiting for a
home run right that's yeah and let's not
forget he did it well uh with a bourbon
and a cigar in in each hand yeah and
beer and hot dogs too exactly that was
that was his steroids
whatever works so okay here in 2022
outside of you hit more home runs you
win a game as a stat what is considered
by the quantitative analysis guys the
holy grail for a player what what is the
thing that you you got that then you're
you're going to the Hall of Fame oh good
one sure
um so obviously I can't talk to what you
know any place anything proprietary
about what people should but I will say
that sort of more generally if you sort
of just sort of look at uh what what
what MVP winners have sort of led the
league in sort of the main stat that
people use is uh now this measure called
ops uh which is on base plus slogging
um so that's sort of a great measure so
what that does it literally takes your
own base percentage so what percent of
plate appearances do you get on base by
any means and it adds to that a slugging
rating and a slugging rating is sort of
like a batting average so
um uh you know what percent of at-bats
do you uh uh do you get a hit but it
rescales it for how how how hard how how
many bases you get on that at that so a
home run is going to be four times as
valuable as a single a double is going
to be twice as valuable as a single and
so when you add on base percentage on
slugging you're sort of combining this
consistency metric which is sort of how
often are you getting on base which is
sort of how valuable are you conditional
on getting on me so for example Aaron
judge this year LED uh uh you know be an
Ops
um he will probably be the MVP if I had
to guess and that sort of tends to be uh
the main metric um and everything is
sort of a very interesting Ben I got to
get this off my chest
um mathematically it is completely
meaningless to add to percentages that
come from different uh Origins it's
completely mathematically meaningless
and every time I see an Ops I cringe
just as a math fluent person I just have
to you do you shout at the TV
you know it's it's like saying
um yo how much what percentage you get
on the exam well I got 90 on the exam or
how much water is left in the glass 50
so let's add the two and believe that
that means something I just can't well
it would mean something if you were
thirsty while you were taking the test
thank you Josh for explaining that to me
okay so that's a new that's the new
darling number then okay yeah and then
what you said actually is is exactly
correct I've actually read some some
studies where they say why are we should
we multiply them instead of add them and
they come up with a multi and say how
would the rankings change so uh there is
no good reason sort of accent to add
them but it actually does have
surprising sort of predictive power uh
so it does sort of work even though it
probably shouldn't
right so and if you if you hit a home
run every time you're back you're
batting four thousand
uh you're yeah you're slugging yeah four
thousand it's four thousand
um yeah wow look at that yeah so so
what's the sneakiest uh stat that means
something that most people would not
think it should mean anything all right
but I got one how close you lean in so
so you get hit by the pitch you take one
for the team oh that's pretty look some
batters get hit more than others it's
not just a random stray ball they're
leaning into this stuff they're not
liked I mean honestly what you just said
kind of I mean I wouldn't be surprised
if that had some significance I mean but
I'd like my My Flesh and skin tissue
intact okay
I got my face I like my face
so we now have new technology thanks to
stackcast that lets us uh see the exit
velocity of a hit so how hard the ball
is hit and
um this has now sort of been adopted uh
both in the main Stream So you see sort
of New York Times articles about it uh
they mentioned it sort of in in in the
uh in the streams of of baseball games
um and people sort of really like this
statistic now that we just didn't have
the ability to measure a long time ago
and
um it tends to have sort of you know a
lot of cool predicted power it sort of
very easily digestible
um and and and how hard you hit the ball
now is is sort of a really important
statistic all right wait a minute now I
got a question for Neil for for physics
so Neil
take what he just said yeah does always
hitting the ball hard means that it's
going to leave the park no the angle
matters they still do from what I've
seen Ben of course they'll give you uh
quote exit velocity except the ball
doesn't exit the field all right and
it's uh so there's some hard hit balls
that go in the Gap that are 100 miles an
hour uh they just didn't have the angle
to then Reach the the stands
um but uh the uh what what intrigues me
is you have all these data from statcast
are there new is there a new thing
people now care about or is it just are
you all are you flooded and can you have
uh what's the term
um uh analysis paralysis
by analysis yeah yeah yeah yeah you have
you have too much data where you think
you have insights but in fact you don't
you just have numbers it's like being in
the serial aisle at the supermarket yeah
okay we do have a huge amount of data we
have more you know now than we did uh uh
many years ago not just sort of we have
more things now on you know every
everything about every pitch and every
hit but also going down to leads that we
never even collected data on uh sort of
vertically
um so I think there are certainly times
where we do not know what to do with
that data um in the sense that you know
there are questions we we haven't
explored or if you you know you suddenly
get a new uh a data stat on for example
how hard every ball was hit you know
what's the first thing you do
um I don't think that uh we're at the
point where we're sort of coming up with
false insights Based on data because I
tend to think that people are very
careful with sort of understanding out
of sample predictability uh and stuff
like that but there's still more data
coming in that was sort of we didn't
have previously either
you know where I think they're getting
something wrong is in the the bat speed
and exit velocity
um and there's this like sweet spot
where the angle that it comes off the
bat that they've been talking about
where you're more likely to get a really
good hit or a home run
um what they're not considering is the
angle that the swing makes to the ground
so so the so in other words the angle
that is more likely to give you a home
run is around 30 degrees plus or minus
however physics tells you the best angle
to send something the farthest is 45
degrees so so why the difference the
difference is if you swing swing swung
if you're swung in a 45 degree angle
then the motion of the bat is in the
same direction as the motion of the ball
and you'll be able to hit the ball 500
feet
but what's happening is you're swinging
horizontally and the ball is coming up
at an angle from it so that the bat is
not entirely moving in the direction the
ball exited the bat and that angle
difference is not showing up in
anybody's statcast that I have seen I
just got to put it out there wow
I actually always wondered that myself
I'm glad to know that I wondered why it
wasn't 45 degrees
and it's because if you're swinging
horizontally every angle that's not
horizontal to the bat has less speed
coming off the bat than the bat does
swinging okay so so so in the limit you
swing and then the ball goes straight up
well you Swang really hard the quote
exit velocity is really fast but it's
not in the direction you need it and the
ball just goes straight up so all of
this matters and I don't see anybody so
they have the numbers but they don't
have all the physics that would matter
here's something else because I'm
getting this off off my chest so the
speed of the pitch Ben
where do they measure the speed of the
pitch
that release at release okay well uh all
data shows that there's an eight up to
an eight mile an hour slowdown of the
pitch by the time it crosses the plate
so the pitcher throws a 95 mile an hour
fastball it crosses my plate at 87 miles
an hour and but the announcers keep
saying boy he blew that 95 mile an hour
fastball right by him but it at the time
it went past him it was 88 miles an hour
well it'll go from 88 to 80 or 100 to
92.
no one's talking about this
Neil is the uh um the baseball cop
sitting behind the billboard
get back to that one again
at clocks yet uh 95. I'm pretty sure I
was only doing 87.
officer I'm I'm pretty sure you know
someone's going to use that as an
argument now you know someone is for
Real gonna use that as an argument okay
Ben I must ask you a bit like Neil off
my chest
you're in one branch of analytics
because we've done shows where it's bio
data it's Tech it's wearables so what
technology maybe don't give away the IP
on the Yankees but is it wearable tech
is it the super high speed cameras for
technique analysis or are we really
opening up with that I got one for you I
guarantee it's not oxygen uptake of the
players okay because they've spent most
of the time just standing there yeah
we're not working worried about lactic
acid buildup in their muscles okay
no there is there is new technology I
mean they just uh you know a lot of
teams now use pitchcom so you no longer
have captures signaling to the picture
what to use they now have microphones
and they pre-program what to say and it
goes into the Hat of the of the picture
that's a new technology but um you know
they're literally hearing voices in
their head yeah well they're literally
hearing voices they took them they took
a page out of football's book because
that used to you know they used to uh
signal plays in and some quarterbacks
cause it and then they just said put a
radio in the helmet this was inspired by
the Astros uh sign stealing uh
um problems in a couple of years ago now
it removes that entirely is it oh yeah
yeah that's what I I read that oh that's
actually kind of cool right you can't
steal the signs and and you know
especially when you're on second base
when you're looking right down the pipe
right yeah it's not a thing continue we
keep interrupting you because we're just
so excited about it so so no uh that's
true I mean you can still still
um steal signs based on sort of where
the cats are setting up even after they
say don't stuff like that but you know
sort of stealing the actual signs that
the catcher made used to be sort of part
of the game that's that's probably
quickly disappearing
um but uh yeah I mean they're always
they're always developing new technology
new camera angles um I don't think sort
of uh in the offices themselves I still
think that bread and butter is going to
be you know plain old data analysis
using using statistical techniques um
and that's always going to do that where
do you think based
base will look
for its new data points in the future
oh I mean are we at that point like you
were saying we're kind of maxed out here
or is there still a lot more to go um I
think we're uh I think the low-hanging
groups keep disappearing and so I think
that the the contributions of analytics
are going to come more and more marginal
likely I mean this can be true in every
sport
um but I do think you know we're we're
sort of constantly getting uh uh new
data and and particularly on sort of uh
pitches and and hitting you know we
didn't even have these sort of exit
velocities for for pitches or or hits
you know accurately seven years ago and
so I think there's still a lot more to
go uh with that probably and let me just
get you a quick opinion this is the last
year of the shift beginning 2023 two
outfielders two infielders have to be on
to the left side of second base and two
on the right side and they can't be so
far back that they're on the grass and
so with this shift
uh I think it'll allow more hits but
could it be that the that the saber
metrics that the data the quantitative
analysis was robbing good batters of
hits and the fans it's not interesting
to fans is that is that a fair statement
yeah so one of the uh one I mean batting
averages have dropped over the past
decade pretty precipitously and you know
shifts have gone up from effectively you
know eight percent I think in 2010 to
about 35 last year and I think a lot of
people say you know one calls the other
and so you know I think that's sort of
what MLB had in mind when they banned
the ship then you know from adapt I'm
going to say a chuck-ism right now I'm
gonna say
they paid millions of dollars to hit the
ball in the other freaking Direction
someplace else hit it someplace else
yeah when everybody says all right guys
to the left let's everybody over to the
left you know you should be like all
right I'm just gonna hit it to the right
okay
I mean it's so simple as a logic however
with the talent that these guys have
it gotta be harder than you think
otherwise they just do it
look if the best you know the best
players in history are hitting the ball
you know 35 of the time uh and now you
want them to aim it I think it's it's a
little more difficult than it looks but
um I got you I I understand what you're
saying I mean yeah uh still uh let's see
what was the last contract 380 million
dollars I believe I mean I'm sure that
was a pitchers contract but I I mean you
know
he's 10 years uh 35 million a year if
somebody if somebody paid me down 460 I
think right so if somebody's turning
down 460 million dollars if you offered
me 460 million dollars I would find a
way to not only place the ball anywhere
on the field I would find a way to catch
it with my teeth and shoot it out of my
ass to do it
Chuck let me tell you if you could do if
you could do all of that as your agent
I'm gonna get you way more than 460
minutes
now now I can't get that out of my head
I gotta like
with me all day Chuck on there that's
locked in now Neil
all right guys we gotta we gotta end it
there so Ben uh good luck sometimes you
need a little bit of that in graduate
school you're in your fourth year and
how long is the program
uh six years six years okay we'll keep
at it and we're delighted to have you on
here give me some insight into the and
and when you own the Yankees remember
the people who you know yeah
remember the people that were behind you
man just remember the guys that
interrupted you alone
all right guys this is uh Neil deGrasse
Tyson you're a personal astrophysicist
uh I'm thinking Ben Morrow for helping
us out here getting a little insight
into baseball data analytics this has
been a start talk explainer as always
keep looking up
foreign
[Music]